escape from Sudan for a lucky few
young and old
helped onto a French evacuation flight
with the capital Under Fire this is one
of the only routes out and it's still
high risk
diplomats and their families given
priority
the UK also in action we have taken the
decision to
temporarily close the British Embassy in
Khartoum to evacuate the British
diplomats and their dependents and
relocate our diplomatic functions into a
nearby diplomatic post
Sky News can reveal details about the
covert British rescue operation
under the cover of Darkness an elite
group of UK troops flew into Khartoum
late on Saturday on an American military
aircraft that was separately evacuating
U.S officials
it's understood the British soldiers
acquired a number of local vehicles and
drove towards the area where the UK
Embassy is located
the troops met with the evacuation party
of around 30 people and prepared for the
extraction
in tandem two Royal Air Force transport
planes a C-130 Hercules and an a400m had
taken off from RAF at criteri a British
base in Cyprus
the aircraft with permission from the
Sudanese military landed on a Sudanese
Airfield Wadi saeeda about 30 kilometers
north of Khartoum at around 1am on
Sunday morning UK time
a window opened of relative calm to
allow the soldiers on the ground to
drive their passengers to the Airfield
the diplomats and families boarded the
aircraft and the two British planes took
off at around 9am UK time and headed
back to Cyprus
Sky News then filmed a coach driving
from the base with a number of those
who'd been rescued
but this place remains a war zone and
the successful Mission will be slim
comfort for the British Nationals still
stranded what I need most is to hear
that there is a plane somewhere outside
of Sudan that plane will come swooping
in we'll get a message saying get to
this point and then we'll get on the
plane and we'll fly home the UK insists
it's not abandoning anyone that can
offer better support from outside the
country the safety and protection of
British Nationals in Sudan remains a
priority for us a top priority for us
British Air Base in Cyprus it's thought
that troops and planes remain on standby
more than 1200 military personnel were
involved in this week's evacuation
the first but possibly not the last such
mission